I don't care about drag queens in the
sense that I don't believe drag queens
are a danger to children I don't believe
drag queens are a prominent or important
political social cultural or economic
issue to be describing or talking about
I just to me drag queens are a non-issue
Republicans have made drag queens an
issue claiming some of the things I just
said I don't believe claiming as
Republicans have that putting together
children and drag queens is dangerous to
the children in some way
um working to get drag queen story hours
of different kinds where men dressed in
drag read stories to kids
um they have made it a political issue
and have claimed that there is a
fundamental immorality to drag queens
and now it turns out that lying
Republican Congressman George Santos
regularly dressed in Drag